it was it was a it was a local business
owner that said you know Jason you took
this company from 170 million awesome
cool story taking it from 70 million to
100 million it's cool but it's not as
cool is doing something that impacts a
hundred thousand people when you grow a
company from seventy to a hundred
million you might affect the CEO and and
the leadership team and maybe your
hundred fifty employees but the stuff
that you could be doing for the city
would affect two hundred thousand people
for generations to come this what work
city certification is really important
and they give you a nice little
framework on what you need to do to get
this certification every step along the
way is basically relating to data and
data governance building data governance
team engaging with citizens using data
making your data visible and open to the
public and accessible what are some of
the metrics things to do with crime pool
attendance that's passionate for people
that kind of shows how your Parks and
Rec and culture is doing ambulance
response time fire response time a lot
of Public Safety type of things like the
number of building permits and the
valuation of building permits I think
that's a good indicator for the trend to
show that that people are investing in
the city population sales tax growth for
US citizen engagement is all about the
user experience a lot of people's
philosophy is do the bare minimum that's
required and we always tried to exceed
that boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Alan sockin we
are on-site in the beautiful Sioux Falls
South Dakota we are now going to be
talking about innovation in Sioux Falls
we have Jason right store for joining us
on the show hi Jason how you doing thank
you so much for coming on the bet so
pumped for this conversation Congrats on
new role with the innovation in the city
of Sioux Falls thank you so pumped for
this convo those that don't know Jason's
background he's the director of
innovation and technology in the city of
Sioux Falls South Dakota this includes
making the city of Sioux Falls one of
the smartest cities in the country by
leveraging data to make decisions and
you can find the links in the Bible of
Sioux Falls org as well as Jason's
Twitter and LinkedIn profiles Jason
let's start things off by asking you
one of our favorite questions what are
your thoughts on the direction of our
world and it's I'll just say that I
think the direction is heading towards
polarization it seems like everything is
just like hot and cold and hot or cold
and and I think there's there's there's
lots of people who live in kind of the
middle ground but but they don't they're
not the ones that are talking like so I
think that's the huge majority it kind
of lives in the in the middle and the
compromising ate space but the people
that kind of have the platform and the
voices are on polar opposites and so I'd
love to see that head back towards the
center a little bit more yeah and one of
the these like first principles is that
it really starts with our own inner
adventure of consciousness and our own
ability to commune with the divine and
our bring our own gifts forth and see
other people as unique that can bring
their gifts forth but then once you
start trying to you know dehumanize
other people and things like that that's
when you get into really bad we don't
want that in society and so like this
first principled understanding of life
of how beautiful this adventurous for us
all and to really treat that as like the
divine experience it is it'll like help
us get away from Samantha I'm like a
golden real guy you know and I think
there's lots of different cultures that
have a variation of if you just do nice
things to others you know they'll do
that nice things to you and you know I
think that's where a lot more of us
should live you know Jason who were you
growing up how did you get interested in
what you care about today so really
always kind of been the Midwest my
family is from the Worthington Minnesota
area and we moved to Sioux Falls when I
was five so I've been a Sioux Falls
resident pretty much my entire life went
to high school here went to college here
met my wife here in cotton high school
we're highschool sweethearts so we've
been together since we were 16 years old
you know
rucifee and so what was your elementary
middle high school in college which ones
so Hayward elementary yeah and axtell
Park Middle School I think we were one
of the last classes that act still
before they build memorial middle school
and then I went to Roosevelt High School
and in August Anna cut for college we've
had my wife and I have had I bought my
very first house I was really into real
estate we bought my first house we were
when we were going to Augie sold that
bought a house and built the house which
was about a mile from her parents and a
mile from my parents and so just back to
our roots on the kind of west side of
Sioux Falls and now we've we've since
built three three new houses and they've
all been within five miles of each other
so we're kind of stepping up through the
property ladder but we love the west
side of Sioux Falls and so we've we've
been here for forever both of us really
have and you guys have two kids two
daughters yeah and they're active and so
I spend a lot as much time as I possibly
can coaching them and their sports or
whatever they want to participate in and
so yeah it's it's it's great I'm I'm I
consider myself a Sioux Falls
through-and-through kind of guy and love
it here I think it's amazing city I just
yeah I love the people I love you know
it's it's big enough to have real events
but it's small enough to still have kind
of a little bit of a hometown community
feel and and so so yeah that's that's me
we both of our parents were kind of a
working-class it didn't seem like we had
we it seems like we were fairly poor
growing up but but we never were without
anything and so I know my parents both
work two and three jobs you know
throughout our entire childhood but
still found a way to get us to every
single sporting event or music event or
whatever else we were participating in
so just the good true working-class
family
growing up and you know I think that's a
big chunk of Who I am today which is
like still really working class at the
heart even though we're doing some cool
innovative things and I argue how did
you pick up what you care about so I
went to Augie my what my wife is
actually one year ahead of me in school
and she decided to go to Augie first so
that naturally I that made my decision
more clear when I was choosing where to
go I actually really wanted to go out of
state and get out of Sioux Falls but
when she chose Augie I wanted to stay
close to her I actually went to Augie on
a choir scholarship I was I was like I
was a decent high school football player
and both the University of Sioux Falls
and a couple of other schools offered me
football scholarships but he offered me
a music scholarship to be in the choir
and like I heard they were going to
China and Ireland and a mic dang that's
the football team's gonna go to like
Orange City Iowa for their big trip you
know I'm like you know taking a little
more easy on the body and and do music
and travel to different places was kind
of the direction that I went and when I
was going on yeah I was really studying
to be I wanted to be a math teacher and
a football coach I loved coaching I I
coached six years in the junior football
program for fifth through eighth graders
we had those boys over to our before my
wife and I had kids we had those boys
over to my house we played Nintendo and
and Playstation or whatever and I just
loved that age of kids and I felt like I
had an impact on them because because
they they trusted me and they believed
in me and and they worked really hard
for me and so I thought that you know
being a teacher and the coach would be a
way that I could impact in a future
generations and so so that's really the
direction I was going at Augie and but
being a Sioux Falls guy like I had I had
a job and it was it was actually one of
my first Jobs was selling cell phones
and it was right in the heart
the boom of from cellular to digital and
I was making so much money part-time a
talkie something that my family had not
really experienced growing up that I
said I kind of was geared towards that
and and so I kind of I went away from
being a teacher and more into the
business mind basically financially
minded they you know just saying I can
make so much more money in the business
world than I can in in teaching and so
that's kind of where my career first
kind of started to stray away from what
I really intended to do and into the
business sector and then maybe even to
be able to do things like take what
financial resources you accrue and then
be able to make what you want to help
people at a more widespread ability with
those financial resources then maybe
that you could without them and just
teaching so it's always interesting
thinking about how to most effectively
be altruistic we you know we talked
about that quite a bit
okay then how did you end up like what
did you end up picking up in this
business world as you continued getting
all the way up to wiser wiser
distributing was this big one that you
most recently yeah I spent I spent I
actually spent seven years playing poker
for a living like I was we were paying
the house payment based on my poker
earnings that missus Hold'em yeah it
Texas Hold'em I traveled all around the
country to all the major tournaments and
played and and actually online poker at
the time was was legal and so being in
South Dakota that's where a lot of my
time was spent on online poker but the
thing about poker that really related
and correlated into business is that for
me I'm a math guy I'm at major type of
mind so it was all about the numbers but
the secondary part of Poker was about
the people and the relationships and
being able to communicate effectively
with people and being able to manage
your money I mean to be successful you
couldn't just like gamble all
and so there's so many of the principles
that I learned playing poker that really
applied the business risk tolerance
negotiation and risk analysis a lot of
those things and so for poker I actually
went into the restaurant business and
ended up being the assistant general
manager at Bennigan's for a couple years
and then into a local pizza franchise
bosses pizza and for me that was really
where I got my first experience into
into business leading teams setting
schedules managing managing vendor
relationships taking care of inventory
you know the budget ppl that's where
that's where I really started to
understand what pl profit and loss yeah
profit and loss cash flow management all
those things so a lot of the principles
that I kind of had first exposure to in
poker really started translated into the
restaurant business for me and then
ultimately from the restaurant industry
I helped a a friend of mine who who I
had known for lots of years in the poker
circuit startup or really grow the
business that that is why is you're
distributing where we started with three
of us in his garage and took it from a
age-old Autobody tool truck where was
just one man one truck going shop the
shop selling auto body tools into a top
50 Amazon seller over the course of
seven years whoa so it was it was an
interesting path to get there but but
but yeah that was the the start of this
thing so okay so in so in seven years
then well let's start with them it's
cool how you were giving us how like
these skills from playing poker can be
applicable to like the business world or
like a lot of times we talked on the
show about kids that are playing video
games they learn a lot of real world
applicable skills as well you know
resource management team
work like build strategies these types
of things and so it's cool how you
brought that up with poker - I think
that's really key and then okay and then
so then you were gaining these the
skills in it's been especially in the
restaurant sector do and that's a big
one - is when you get really immersed in
the restaurant sector and you tit
especially in a managerial role you
start seeing how the operations work and
you gain deeper empathy and better
understanding of business and then okay
so then you find yourself with wiser and
so then you guys are you have sense auto
body parts yeah the the business at the
core started as Auto Body tools and
supplies so polishes and waxes and and
sandpaper for for painting your car or
restoring a car that's what the business
started as we we took that that age old
business of auto body tool sales and put
it all online online and so but not an
urgent both on the the domain that you
owned as waz amazon where did you
migrate most of the sales to one of the
yeah we started as both and we were
actually really agnostic when it came to
the channel whether it was our site or
eBay or Amazon or whatever we just
wanted it to be available for anybody we
were really good at shipping that I had
a I had a personal side gig along the
way of selling baseball and softball
equipment and so I was really really
comfortable with eBay really really
familiar with the best practices on how
to ship and how to get good feedback and
how to interact with customers that's
how I got involved in this wiser
distributing when Eric Weiser was the
son of the founder of the company was
gonna take it over he really wanted to
find efficiencies in how to ship these
things all over the world and so that
was really my background and his
business that merged and and really
focused on being able to sell these
things to anywhere in the world so we
were doing like a million dollars in
sales locally in Sioux Falls by the end
of I think the second or third year we
tripled that online
yeah yeah so our reach just became
really really wide and became online
about seven years ago yeah that we we
really migrated online 2011 yeah that's
what that's when I started with a
company well and and that just like open
open up the world for us and and so
while we started as Auto Body tools we
now I say we cuz like I'm still a little
bit involved in terms of advising the
company we we are now into hunting and
fishing okay toys mouth or games doll
clothes like I mean everything like
interesting the the scope of the SKUs or
the number of products is is I think
when I started we had 300 items and now
I think they have 40,000 items and so
all different verticals all different
markets all the from vendors 40,000 SKUs
to manage that is crazy what were some
of the shipping best practices that
you've implemented so Amazon was kind of
the king of customer service and they
their standards of a fast and free we
really brought that into our business
eBay had like their requirements was
three to five days but we we our goal
was to always exceed it and so we wanted
to mirror Amazon's best practices of two
day shipping into a three to five day
environment and nobody else was doing
that and so I think our customers
recognize the fact that dang these guys
really deliver above and beyond what the
expectations are and and so for that
that just remained a focus and so our
best practice is you know if it came if
the order came in before two o'clock we
wanted to get it out that same day and
our shipping team and our warehouse team
bought into that strategy and it really
service really well moving forward so
kind of you know I think the a lot of
people's philosophies do the bare
minimum that's required and we always
tried to exceed that and so that was
kind of the best practice for us we also
utilized the the USPS the US Postal
Service's flat rate system which I don't
think a lot of other people are doing a
lot of people were
shipping via UPS and FedEx and just kind
of paying whatever the rate will we
figured out the the items that fit best
in this fixed-rate deal and so if we
could condense the most money into a
fixed-rate box like that that went
straight to the bottom line and so we
really found a ton of efficiencies and
and and customer customer satisfaction
through some of those best practices so
yeah it's crazy thinking about how to
take 40,000 SKUs and be able to like
take a purchase order in and then just
be able to really quickly identify where
it is an inventory and put it in a box
and ship it to the right person is that
kind of what you guys were doing and
trying to automate that process
effectively we started in the garage and
so the inventory was just like laying on
the floor all the way I cried and so
there was no automation there was no
like SKU we were not tracking SKUs we
just we the orders would come in we'd
print it off and we'd walk through the
garage and try to figure out where this
thing was and so that was the early days
and then quickly we figured out like if
this thing is gonna grow we need to have
appropriate space and so we bought our
first warehouse and we set up at the
time we still laid all the inventory
along the walls in the warehouse it was
just a bigger warehouse and we had one
shelf and that was like our hot shelf
where we liked our fastest moving items
just fit onto one shelf like you'd find
in your garage but that quickly turned
into like 350 hot shelves and so we
actually then had to figure out a way to
catalog the inventory and just like
basic basic inventory management stuff
that we were just learning as we went we
were we always said we were we were
writing the blueprint as we were
building the house for that business and
I think that's true of a lot of
entrepreneurs that are just like get in
and figure out we failed a lot but we
failed fast and we just we evolved
really quickly and adjusted and so that
was just like the mantra of this
business and we tried to our big I
always told people I have no idea what
we sold specifically I never worried
about the products I was so there was
plenty of people in our organization
that worried about the products I was
worried about the people
and that was exactly what I worried
about in the restaurant business and and
all the other businesses if I could
figure out the people and make a process
that was sustainable and scalable then
the products didn't matter
we could sell doll clothes or we could
sell auto body tools it did not matter
we just we focused on hiring really
great people yes stellar people in
process yeah how did it end up coming up
this innovation and technology in Sioux
Falls gig and how did you end up being
like okay it's time to make this
transition so that was interesting so
about a year ago our our current mayor
paulten Hagin was he was going he was he
was going through his campaign and and
so we invited him out to our business as
one of the fast-growing businesses in
South Dakota and he was interested in
seeing kind of what our operation was
and and so we invited him out to our
warehouse and we talked me through our
process and we kind of told him like how
fast you're growing you clearly
interested in that piece and and that
was really the first time that I met him
and had any discussions with him and and
and from there he goes on to be elected
mayor and he takes a class through the
Harvard Bloomberg initiative on city
leadership and it was at that class that
he really started to be exposed to this
idea of innovation and I teams and
cities and the Bloomberg program was
really supportive of some of these
cities that are trying this method of
innovation city innovation and so when
he got back from that Leadership
Initiative he called me up and said hey
I want to rebrand this department in
Sioux Falls that used to be central
services and it was kind of the central
dumping ground for all issues like IT
lived there and a multimedia support
lived there which is basically just a
place where all the problems started to
flow to you and he's like I want to take
this department and really turn it from
being reactive into being a strategic
partner citywide
and he said would you be interested and
I actually I said that's amazing I think
it's a great idea let me know how that
goes for it you know and and so you kind
of let that settle and then a few weeks
later he called me he's like so I am
gonna move forward with doing this and
would you be interested in you know
being the director of this department
and I'm like no he called me on the day
that I was golfing with the CEO of why
should I share like my uh the mayor's
calling and answered so he's basically
asking me if I want to do this while I'm
sitting next to my partner the business
and my first response was no like I'm
I'm in a great place we're a fast
growing company we're killing it and
he's like well you know do you think
about it I'd like to talk to you one
more time about it and we ended up
having one more lunch conversation and
we just talked about the impact that
this position could make and the goals
and the objectives and the type of work
that it would be doing and and I really
had this deep down pit in my stomach
servant service minded approach I was I
was certain I'm currently the president
of my church council and our church went
through a really tough phase where a lot
of people left the church and I was just
called to bring these people back in and
be involved and so I had this this thing
in my stomach that just told me I wanted
to be doing something more meaningful
than dropping money to the bottom line
of a fast growing business and and so
that lunch where he ends up saying you
know I want you to do this I said I
don't know anything about technology I
don't know anything about innovation I
don't know he's like I you don't have to
worry about that part you just need you
to lead a team and I'm not leading teams
I can do I know how to build teams I
know how to how to be great leader or
try to be you know a great leader and he
knew something about innovation
technology with doing wiser I mean
that's the work that we were doing there
was some of the same work that we would
need to be doing in the city of Sioux
Falls and so so I had I went through a
little period of discernment where I you
know talked with my pastor and talked to
some people that I trusted and it had to
be outside my circle of wiser
distributing because I didn't want to
like get into a negotiation with him it
wasn't about
the money really is really about the
call to serve and and I can't remember
it was it was a it was a local business
owner that said you know Jason you took
this company from 170 million awesome
cool story like taking it from 70
million to 100 million it's cool but
it's not as cool is doing something that
impacts 100,000 people you know when you
when you grow a company from 70 to 100
million you might affect the CEO and and
the leadership team and maybe you're 150
employees but the stuff that you could
be doing for the city would affect
200,000 people for generations to come
and and so when I started to wrap my
head around the fact that this type of
work could be really impactful for a
huge chunk of people that maybe can't
fight for themselves that's really what
made me take the leap from private
sector into the public sector and so
I've been doing that for for 10 months
now yeah you're the fast that's right
this last year it yeah
this is huge okay so alright so now
let's let's endeavor into what this is
all is so you kind of gave us this idea
at the very you you mentioned this like
like Bloomberg is now looking at fast
growing like mid market cities and they
have kind of their eye on helping those
cities that are geared towards this not
reactive problem-solving but rather
strategic development of innovation
inside their cities and Bloomberg is
like taking the mayors and bringing them
to these leadership development summits
in like again for like working with you
guys on this thing called what works
City WWC and so this is like there's 51
checkpoints or milestones that these
cities can have and that if you get 26
of them done you get this first round of
certification yeah so is this kind of
then what this is kind of like would you
say that like the template for
innovation and and technology inside of
growing cities yeah so we for us in
Sioux Falls this department did not
exist
ten months ago 12 months ago so we're
we're basically birthing this thing from
scratch and making the blueprint as you
go yeah we're building the innovation
blueprint as we build the innovation
house we recognize that lots of cities
that are working towards this what work
city certification are doing work that
would translate to Sioux Falls in a
meaningful way and instead of just kind
of using gut instincts to make decisions
these cities are starting to use data to
drive decision making everything from
budget to where they build fire stations
to you know what what works in libraries
you know and best practices and stuff
like that so we this this what works
city certification is really important
and they give you a nice little
framework on what you need to do to get
this certification and every step along
the way is basically relating to data
and data governance building and data
governance team and and engaging with
citizens using data making your data
visible and open to the public and
accessible and so we've we've our goal
is to achieve this certification within
the next year and so we've got like 9
out of the 26 steps done we think to
their satisfaction and so we're putting
a really focused effort to achieve those
those next you know 15 to 20 things that
help us get the certification not only
because the certification kind of gives
you a little check mark and a status
symbol but because if we accomplish this
we will have actually been using data to
drive decisions and I think that's
really important in a world where
there's limited FTEs or full-time
equivalents there's limited capacity and
workers you can't just like keep hiring
people we're a unionized environment
like with our civil service employees
and there's just rules you just can't
add and take away people like you can in
the private sector and so we have to do
more with the same or less people
and normally in the private sector if
you wanted to do a new initiative you
just hire that person you send them on
their way well you just can't do that in
the public sector and so for us data is
gonna be crucial to maximize the use of
our people and and to make those
decisions easier and more clear and so
we're really committed to this WebWork
City certification plan
I love the making decisions based on
data and really building like this this
data refinery in essence actually being
able to take in all these streams of
data inputs and then make sense of them
and make the best decisions Eve this
example where with like City Planning
stuff it was just whatever a couple
people that would get together in a room
and just talk about it and only three
people would show up versus when you
actually took the conversation and
brought it online and then you had
10,000 views you had people engaging in
the comments and then the was you know
roads potholes and what was the third
one yeah so just basically
infrastructure structure in general was
what people wanted to be solved and then
the City Planning was able to move
forward with that instead of just what
three people in a room were talking
about so basically what you're doing is
you're getting to what is happening at
the edge in these more you're closer to
what's happening in people's real lives
because you're bringing them into the
equation and then they're then able to
contribute to what developments they
want to happen I make a lot of
correlations and to the private sector
and what we did for our best practices
on fast and free basically that means
making the the user experience better
and bringing the user closer to like
what their desired outcome is and so for
us
citizen engagement is all about the user
experience and that's actually you know
it was debatable you know I'm in the
room with a bunch of people from from
all over the country that are doing this
too
work and a lot of these people are
twenty and thirty year veterans and in
the industry and in their cities
and I'm sitting here with ten months
under my belt saying why am I here like
what am i but but I'm so close to being
one of those end-users that like I think
that's an advantage and so the newer you
are kind of in in this role it helps you
understand like what these users wanted
in so for me personally like my favorite
way to interact was not to go down to
the library and sit in the Town Hall to
participate my favorite way to interact
was through social media through
Facebook through Twitter through
whatever and and listening to podcast
and interacting and watching shows I was
not interested in in sitting through a
six hour seminar on public works right
but I'd but I could engage in a way that
was easy and efficient for me and and so
that's what we're trying to do with our
with our citizen engagement - we're
trying to bring the issues into your
living room so you can make it you know
everybody's busy and so we don't want
you to drive down the library and sit in
this meeting we want to bring it to you
and so when that when the mayor he's got
a great following on social media when
he when he raised up hey what do you
what do you guys think we should do with
our budget next year the comments just
started it was just a comment every
other one was roads roads roads potholes
potholes streets infrastructure we've
went through we went through a phase
where we built a lot of cool things in
Sioux Falls like the Aquatic Center and
and the premier Center and those are
great venues to go but at the end of the
day people wanted to take care of what
we've already got
that was just a common theme and so
through social media and through these
social engagements that became a
priority for us in our budgeting and 85
percent of our budget next year is gonna
be spent on roads and infrastructure
we're not buying you new things that
that are cool and exciting we're taking
care of oh we've already got that was
all made possible through the the
citizen engagement tool that were using
so in this is great so he engaged
citizens and then we take the data
stream that would get from being gay
then we had closed the feedback loop by
acting on what they want which is you
know in this case it was roads and
potholes and infrastructure in general
so then what were some of those in nine
other ones that you guys have out of the
51 or else a lot of it had to do with
public facing dashboards and so we take
that data and we built the dashboard
that was a quick win that we got early
in in my role is to create a citizen
dashboard that lives right on our main
page and we've kind of got nine KPIs
that we think are important that
citizens are constantly asking about
like if you were on a desert island how
could you tell how your city of Sioux
Falls was doing hopefully this dashboard
tells that story and so that was that
was kind of the first that's one of that
was one of the nine things and and so
it's what are some of the metrics that
are on it so like things to do with
crime things to do with pool attendance
that's passionate for people is pool
attendance that kind of shows how your
Parks and Rec and culture is doing
ambulance response time fire response
time a lot of Public Safety type of
things the other thing that's on there
is like the number of building permits
and the valuation of building permits I
think that's a good indicator for the
trend of building permits to show that
that people are investing in the city
population just some of those type of
things sales tax growth that's like
we're funded the entire city is funded
through sales tax really and and so
keeping an eye on on that you know the
effects that that our local sales tax
climate has had based on some rulings
that they've made on online sales tax
has actually proven to be a little bit
of an accelerator which we we kind of
knew that it would be but if there was a
huge dip in sales tax we knew that we
maybe have to make some changes in the
future budget cycles you know that are
more conservative but with tax sales tax
growth being positive we can be a little
bit more aggressive in some of the
initiatives that were pushing out so
those are the and then each one of those
things has a more info button where you
can do if you know if you we wanted it
super easy for like Joe Joe average user
to be able to take a visual but we also
want it accessible for the
like the dead X and the data nerds that
wanted to dive in deeper and so each one
of those opens up to a deeper trailing
history and and so we focused a lot on
that and we're gonna actually try to
roll the concept of dashboards into all
the different departments we think it's
a really good accountability tool if you
if you don't measure it you can't really
manage it and and so if all of our
departments had their own dashboard
streets for example like number of
potholes a number of road miles and
whatever if they have that dashboard
accessible to them it's a it's a tool
that can help them maintain
accountability and we want that to exist
for all the departments in the city I
love that the visualization of data
making it clean making it accessible
making it transparent and then being
able to act on it fast what about some
of those other ones a lot of it is the
storytelling component you know building
having a governance having a team built
to work on this
having the mayor's you know some of it's
as simple as having your mayor tweet or
or publicly endorse the support of this
program and they want it to really be
like a top-down approach in terms of
support and so both again we started
with the some of the easiest things like
simple things of you know just having
the mayor being involved one of them is
design a process that uses data to make
policy and so that's the one we're
working on right now it's not checked
off yet but but when you start to get to
that level that says based on this data
we're gonna write this policy that's big
deal city ordinance that that's not this
and so so we're getting we're getting
there like
yeah you gave me some other examples on
you proactively inspecting buildings
that would have prevented 85% of fires
this is kind of this is really critical
stuff so you can actually crunch data to
predict the in the census is like
building pathology or something you
could call it like the disease of
buildings over time and their fire
sensitivity and proclivity for fire to
occurrence if you can then manage that
and prevent it then you can save lots of
money save lives cetera the fire
department has a certain amount of FTEs
dedicated to building inspections they
can get to X number per year just period
and it's not a hundred percent of the
buildings in Sioux Falls they cannot get
to all of them and so our team set up a
table of data that that cross-reference
square footage age the building
proximity to fire hydrants like a lot of
different data points and we figured out
which ones were the most impactful and
we used that day that we said if we
instead of just canvassing the whole
city in some random order if we were
intentional about the inspections based
on the priority that the data says that
we should we we could have taken those
same two FTEs prioritized them into the
high risk properties not inspected the
ones that had zero risk of fire based on
the data and we could have we could have
inspected 85% of the fires that happened
over the last 10 years proactively and
maybe would have prevented some of those
fires by making code enforcement
improvements or things like that and so
there again it's like it's taking a
limited resource which for us is
personnel hours and deploying them
intentionally rather than just random
and so for us that's that's the
predictive analytics piece that we're
really trying to incorporate into lots
of different departments is we're
limited on resources we're limited on
budget it's taxpayer money and so you've
got
like get the most bang for your buck
that's what the innovation team is
really working on it's I'd love to say
that we're working on flying cars and
back the future type of stuff but in one
day someday we will right now we're
trying to solve old problems with with
new ideas and new ways of doing things
something that and and all these
departments are so busy that they don't
really have time or energy to focus on
that type of thing which is exactly what
the innovation team is focused on and a
really simple one is like the city's
growing like where do you put the next
fire station where do you put the next
high school right how do you figure out
where to do these things yeah we're
hoping and we're gonna partner with a
couple of the area colleges we're gonna
partner with USDA we're gonna partner
with Augie they're both of those schools
are are working to build up a data
analytics course and and program and
we're gonna we're gonna partner with
them to to make some of those decisions
and help us make some of those decisions
and and that's that's why we we worked
so hard on making our data open and
accessible so that anybody can be able
to take those data sets and apply it
towards a project or technique and I
think it is important because you don't
want to just guess where a fire station
should go like there should be some real
justification based on data based on
proximity whatever the key metrics are
so that you're really intentional about
and then building the right size fire
station and and have you know like all
those things so it's it's basically
taking like the gut instinct of things
and being intentional about it you guys
also built an app that geo-located
potholes which I thought was great as
well so you can do something as simple
as just take a picture and then that way
it's geo-located and that way the Public
Works Department knows if what if it's a
pothole what it looks like how to they
can go out fast and fix it there could
be a conversation with the person that
took it it's like engaging again there's
these little wins that you guys have had
we really wanted to focus on some
low-hanging fruit to build some
credibility for our department and build
some trust for other departments that
that kind of proved that what we were
working on was important and this
pothole it's not really a pothole app
it's app that that you are able to
report potholes that's the majority of
the the issues that are reported are
potholes but it can do everything from
like if you see graffiti on a public
building snap a picture somebody'll
dress it or or if the neighbors grass is
too long and instead of calling in for a
code enforcement you can just snap a
picture of it and it'll work into the
right departments this was a game
changer for us for a couple of reasons
one the citizens were yearning for
something that was more efficient than
calling it most people don't even have
home phones and so like the process of
looking up the number and dialing in and
talking to somebody trying to explain it
just was is it's not a good use of any
ways time and so at their leisure they
can just snap a picture and hit one
button and boom it's in our system and
not only is it our system but somebody
from the city will respond to you and
and people love the fact that there's
this two-way communication you can go
back and forth and and so if somebody
takes a picture of a traffic light that
says this light sucks it's too slow at
this spot our traffic engineer will
actually come in and have a conversation
with you and says here's why and and
yeah we can work on this or maybe we
should do this and so there's this back
and forth interaction to a communication
that's been a huge win for the streets
department by actually being able to see
a picture of the issue instead of having
somebody describe it over the phone they
can then deploy the right type of
equipment to the scene so a lot of
people describe what they think is a
pothole that's actually a frost boil I
have no idea what the difference is but
somebody the streets department does and
so if I would call in and describe a
frost boil as a pothole the old method
is that they would send the pothole crew
but they wouldn't be equipped to fix
that issue and so this has really helped
us be efficient with our with our people
and our resources and not only that but
it's geo-located
instead of having a grandma call in and
say it's over near 85th and whatever
it's actually geo-located and they can
drive right up to it and know exactly
where it's at and so that for us this is
super low cost low implementation
timeline and and it checks a lot of the
boxes of citizen engagement and creating
efficiencies and so we're looking for
those kind of things that's that's an
example of actually applying technology
towards innovation yes and a low-hanging
fruit that the guys got to say that hey
we got this one in it's really solid
yeah and then how about let's talk about
as you know your your going for these
bigger ideas as well because you you've
done this process of building
credibility and Trust so you have the
public transit thing is kind of
interesting like so many of the cities
especially in the United States United
States is such a large country that we
have cities especially in the suburban
areas that are quite widespread where
basically you have to have a you have to
have your own personal vehicle to get
around from place to place because it's
inefficient for your time to use public
transit it's also just like we were just
talking about there's like a person at a
time riding these buses that are on
these kind of more older routes and so
this program in the city what is it that
it's spent nine million dollars on the
transit system and we only bring in
600,000 and fare so it's kind of like
what do we do about this behemoth and
how do we innovate an updated that was I
went to the one of the first luncheons
that I went to that the mayor was
speaking at somebody asked him a
question and he said we've got this nine
million dollar transit system that's
failing and that's the first thing I'm a
job on Jason's desk on his first day of
work I was like what I don't know
anything about transit I've never even
ridden one of our buses I have no idea
about anything and and so we actually it
is a mammoth behemoth monster that that
several task force have worked on over
the last few administrations and
nobody's really come up with a good
solution for this and so so yeah talk
about like high expectations that they
want
that's what happened with this but we
were supported through the Harvard
Bloomberg team and they actually sent us
a design coach that that taught us the
principles of human centered design and
so I built a team that was made up of of
12 different departments in the city
attended four departments in the city
made up of 14 people intentionally they
had no history or knowledge of transit
because we wanted to approach this with
the mentality that was totally fresh
totally clean so my requirements were
you had to have high energy you had to
be really open to change and you
couldn't be the type of person that said
this is how we've always done it before
like that's a game changer it kills a
game in the innovation world if you if
you come to the table and just say we
can't do that because that's not how
we've always done it before like that's
completely the opposite of what our
departments goals are and so we built
this team and we studied the transit
system we figured out that we had these
routes from 20 30 years ago over the
same routes and there just say there's
so many potentials for like
combinatorics in terms of ideas and
where you could go and so just drop that
from your mentality this idea of like oh
the way that we've been doing it is best
it's like there's so much more future
options that could be better and so like
to creatively explore those is so
critical yeah I think very similar to
that thinking is the rules say that we
can't do that and so we can't do that
and my approach is so can we change the
rules right can you rewrite policy can
you can you lobby for new laws so that
the rules aren't this thing that limits
you yeah and I'm not saying we should
just go out and change a bunch of rules
or break rules or anything like that but
like when people fall back on that's not
how we can't do it because of this or
it's not how we've always done it that
stifles innovation and creativity and
everything right there and it's just
it's just over so that's that's my
mantra and my team knows that it's like
do not come to me and say we can't do
this because of that like we have to
tell me why we can do something not why
can't do something and and so this team
approached it like that having no
experience we figured out that this nine
million dollar a year system was only
bringing in six hundred thousand in
fares we could literally figured out on
day one we could literally give
everybody that rode the bus a free uber
ride we could pay for their Marad and we
could save like three million dollars a
year and so it's just because you know
Sioux Falls you can get anywhere you
want to go in basically 15-20 minutes
right if you have a car you can leave
your house and get anywhere you need to
go in 15-20 minutes and so public
transit because we're kind of a
sprawling city the the fixed routes have
not grown as the city's grown and it's
they've been centralized and so all the
services we figured out through the
human Center design process and
interviewing riders that actually use
the system that it was failing them in a
way that the services were getting
pushed to the edge of town affordable
housing and in health care clinics we
interviewed one of the large employers
in town they said that the people that
they hired had to go get drug testing at
a facility that wasn't covered by a
public transit route and these people
didn't have vehicles and so for they
what they wanted was for us to to create
a fixture out that would loop people
into that thing well the cost of adding
that fixture out is enormous and we're
never going to bring enough fares to
cover that cost so we had to really
think about it from a completely
different angle and what our group came
up with through tons of engagement with
riders and stakeholder interviews and
talking the people at the car lovers
that that are never going to use no
matter what you know that was a
stakeholder group we still wanted their
opinion on and employers and school
district and everybody we had tons and
tons of these meetings we figured out
that it didn't operate where people
wanted it didn't operate when people
wanted like it didn't run it doesn't run
on Sundays well one of the biggest users
of our transit system is in
the hospitality area the house keepers
of hotels their number-one day of the
week for work is on Sundays and so the
people that needed it the most
we're not using it on the day that they
needed it the most and so we tried to
solve it from how do we get more
coverage more time today more frequent
so you get people some of these people
we figured out we're spending an hour
and a half on these loops to get to
their appointment well if they're doing
that twice a day either basically
burning three hours of their life yeah
every day where they could just be doing
20 minutes right yeah so our goal was to
could we find a system that had more
coverage more times faster and and do it
for as much or less as the current
system and what we came up with is is
this idea to take our existing fleet of
buses we have like 23 buses in the city
that run on 12 different routes could we
use those almost like a shared lift or
shared uber and there's lots of cities
across the country that are exploring
the ideas of micro transit and transit
on demand and we kind of came up with a
hybrid approach that we could use our
existing fleet which we own so we don't
have any extra cost or whatever week we
could use our existing drivers and
instead of driving around the city with
empty buses for people that aren't
riding we just park the buses until
somebody needs and we just go pick them
up and along the way if there's similar
people on a similar route you could you
could start to like you know find some
efficiencies in having the shared bus
route and so we it's almost as though
then it should just be your knee on the
buses so I understand that that that's
the that's that that is an asset that
has owned already but there's so much
inefficiency we're driving a bus for a
single person that's trying to take the
bus versus a single person was in or
just a car being driven by a person but
then you'd have to purchase those assets
and stuff but this is interesting that
more cities that are more spread out
they're potentially more efficient for
the city to
do like a shared uber system for for
public transit instead of potentially
buses whereas when you're in like metros
people are stacked on top of each other
yeah and so the population density is
there so that you can have the route
that's right that has a building that
block has maybe ten thousand people
living on just that block and so it
makes more sense to have a bus the buses
going through there versus here it's
like what like you know they'll be like
a hundred people live that block so
we're actually again hoping to use data
so that's going to be our you know
whatever technology that we implement
here one of the rules are that one of
our demands is that we're gonna have
we're gonna own the data the ride data
the origin and destination data we think
that there's probably what we were
hoping that we find reasons to downsize
these these buses you know and there's
gonna be maybe be a mix of ten huge
buses and ten half-size buses and ten
shuttles or vans and depending on where
people are going and how many people are
moving like you deploy the right size
vehicle you know to the right size
situation so more efficient for people's
time and saving money from the old from
the budget yeah it's quite interesting
the way you can innovate on something
that's like archaic yeah like that
transit system we think that there's
gonna be room to bring the fixed routes
back in based on the origin and
destination there's gonna be some fixed
routes that gonna that makes sense based
on some density and and so we're looking
at a heat map right now of the number of
available jobs in relationship to where
the affordable housing our low-income
housing is and figuring out if there's
justification for creating a route just
between those you know those areas and
so we don't have any data now that's the
thing this this archaic system doesn't
really have data that's useful and so we
we're doing this not only to increase
the coverage but to start to get some of
that data that helps us you know make
better decisions on where to put these
things
so that's a really exciting program the
its man if I have no idea if it's good
we really hope it's gonna work but if it
doesn't like we'll just have to pave it
and find something else because at the
end of the day the people that are using
the public transit now need it they they
have no they don't have access to a car
they can't afford a car and so we have
to make this accessible and and and we
have to figure this thing out and we're
just hoping that we can exhaust all the
options for this before we have to go to
the council and ask for more money yeah
we believe in you the way that you're
looking at tackling this is great yeah
yeah all right
5g what's going on with Sioux Falls this
have passion for becoming one of the
first mid market cities of 5g technology
John Thune is a state senator he sits on
the committee that is really working on
this he's at home Sioux Falls is his
hometown and so he was passionate about
making his hometown you know one of the
first mid market cities to have 5g so we
brought in he helped us facilitate
conversations with FCC chairman and and
you know targeted Sioux Falls as an
option I'll just tell you that it's a
lot of it is out of our hands
it's in the hands of the carriers that
actually are gonna be putting up the
towers the role that the city can play
and our innovation team can play is
we're trying to do the best we can to
facilitate ease of access to this the
permitting process and the design
process we're trying to take out as much
friction as possible to streamline this
process so that I mean they're doing
this in cities all over the country the
cities we our hypothesis is that the
cities that are the best partners and
the and make it the easiest for these
carriers to to deal with it are going to
be the ones that get it first and so we
have weekly updates and interactions
with with both major carriers and and so
we've actually got 18t and Verizon yeah
for for Sioux Falls where we've got
contracts with AT&T and Verizon right
now
we've got ten tower locations actually
in our permitted process and the plans
are being reviewed and I think they're
set to go up in the next in a few weeks
we're hoping we're hoping to that these
go well and then they want to they want
to do 500 more you know in the next year
or so but I like how you explain that
it's better for us to just help enable
the the more frictionless process for
innovation and then that can then
catalyze lots of other innovation and
growth that happens in the city versus
just trying to like slow things down and
and have like profiteer on some of the
towers going up and whatnot I do and
have mentioned this on the show before
just the importance of slowing down in
the sense of figuring out some of the
longitudinal effects that 5g technology
could potentially have on our biology
and there's a lot of other things that
that funnel into this with neuro tech
and biotech and AI and the way that we
engage with smart devices and then how
we engage with each other we just need
to do a little bit more tests on how
these things are affecting us prior to
necessarily just running forth blindly
into the trans human transition that
we're going through I totally agree with
you we're definitely not the experts on
the health or any of that type of thing
but we also don't want to be we don't
want to come up with solutions to
problems that we don't we're not sure
exists and so we we just want to be a
good partner in the process and we'll
let the experts kind of sort through
some of those you know best practices
but the the stark truth is that there's
way more devices in this world than
there are people and the board you know
every / thats growing exponential it is
and say oh TRS coming
the you know Henry's of billions of IOT
devices now everything from healthcare
and doing surgeries remote and all those
things you know 5g really a lot of
people think of it like oh cool I can
download a two-hour movie in 14 seconds
well that's nice but the real fact of
the matter is that there's we need more
lanes for these devices to travel and so
that we can start to communicate in real
time you know this this public transit
thing probably involves some version of
connected vehicles autonomous vehicles
in the future ten years ago we didn't
have a BER and and so we don't know
what's gonna be here in another 10 years
but we think that you know the benefits
of 5g in a connected world in a the
Weisse world really outweighs the
resistance for why not to do it and and
so we're we're we're again we're just
trying to like set the PlayBook up for
success and and be good partners with
these people and and so far there are
our feedback from the carrier's is that
word like top-notch city for hospitality
and and creating this frictionless
process and and so that's the track
we'll take for the next several months
as we implement this I like how you also
mention this to me this that there's
this firstnet which is the dedicated 5g
channel for first responders and AT&T
won that contract I just like how we
have at least the foresight to say that
hey there should be a dedicated channel
for first responding yeah that's huge
we of course I we and you know our
cities contract is with Verizon but
knowing that ATT has this contract with
firstnet we're at least testing it
there's 20 devices in the city right now
in our vehicles our police and fire
vehicles that are testing the firstnet
system right so we're not we're not I am
NOT a fan of like all or nothing I love
pilots
love testing i lost yeah i love i love
trying it yeah and there's this like
there's this phrase that one of the
professors that elicits you said that
this there's like this entropy of
shittiness which is when you try to roll
something out and it's like a two-year
timeline for the rollout by the time
that it actually gets rolled out things
have changed so much but you don't roll
out the right thing yeah and and so
instead of that like being agile and
testing and trying new things all the
time like I think is way better than
setting this strict timeline code you're
probably the screw-up along the way and
then rush to do this thing that's wrong
and we're newer technologies already out
by that time
yeah so stuff yeah what is the harm in
testing this thing and trying this thing
and at least getting the information and
so that's like that cities are kind of
like then like little permutations of
different creative potentials and so to
be able to run those like firstnet's and
whatnot out okay let's talk about what
has been your relationship with the
divine or with source or god what's been
your relationship with that we so I'm
I'm ELC a Lutheran that's the that's my
practice and we've kind of have been
from and I was baptized early age and we
grew up kind of in the church and
Vacation Bible School and and Bible Camp
in the summer and and and so so my
relationship you know is is is I think
fairly strong with God my version of God
like I I don't I I think there's room
for everybody to have their own beliefs
and I really don't try to push certain
beliefs a strong way but I just
appreciate the fact that everybody kind
of has their own opinions on how things
should go and I try to set I try to
surround myself by like-minded like
cultured people and for us my church the
fellowship of the people that go to my
church it's just this really strong
support
network my dad was killed in a racing
accident when I was 14 years old so 25
years ago and you know so my mom
instantly became a single mom of two
kids that were active you know I'm
fourteen eleven year old kids no father
figure and our church family really
surrounded us with support and they
helped get me my brother to our events
and so I said earlier like this golden
rule of do you want to others as you'd
like to be done unto you I believe in
that and so and and so my faith and my
relationship with God is in that in that
vein um I like to be around I like to
help people I like to be around people
that like to help other people and and I
think like that grassroots effort of
being nice to people and being kind is
really powerful so and then and then
tell us about this like this feeling of
communion with a higher power where word
is that how does that feel like to you I
struggle I'll be honest I struggle with
like science
part of this right like I'm a trust but
verify kind of guy
but there's been so many moments that
just seem a little too coincidental
you know synchronicities coincidence you
know and and and so my relation it's
been a like a back-and-forth struggle
you know and like when you you know
leave your dad at early age you have
doubts and you like but then like
somehow you get rushed back into this
thing and so I just I I trust I just I
just trust I try to I try to be very
gracious for the things that I've been
given and you know try to a lot of
people I think pray in their worst
moments but I think you should also pray
in some of your best moments and and so
I like to it's I think it's just a
constant the evolution of
of learning knowledge and relationship
and and and so I'm I've I don't have all
the answers and so I think it's still
yet to be determined but continues to
evolve and and I feel really good about
you know teaching my kids you know the
messages and the stories that I've
learned and and hopefully hopefully that
kind of a church relationship faith
relationship translates into your
community relationship and so that's
kind of where I'm at with that do you
feel like consciousness emerges from the
process of biological evolution errs
there's some spirit or soul that comes
to meet the physical body for an
experience mmm I've never been asked
that question before I said it's it one
more time if consciousness emerges from
biological evolution or if there's some
sort of a spirit or soul that comes and
takes its seat in the body I I kind of
think there's a little bit of a mix of
both and because you know like the
biological I watched both my kids be
born and take the very first breath I
can't explain that but you know even
though I think the science the biology
is really the catalyst for this but it's
it's just amazing like the way that the
brain starts to fire and their synapses
and whatever just starts to fire
immediately it just seems like it's too
complex to be random you know so I I
think it's a it's it's a little mix of
both where the biology like starts this
but you know the spirit really like
starts to light you up the first time
like you you start to the eyes recognize
the parents eyes and so I haven't spend
enough time to answer that really well
other than my gut instinct is is I think
there's a little bit of room for both
what would be a principle that you would
recommend young people and adults moving
into the exponential technology age what
could maximize people bringing their
gifts into the world mmm I think I think
that lots of people have really good
ideas and and I talked about this
earlier the people that are living in
the middle I believe are the very
minority in the in being vocal and
sharing their ideas and sharing their
opinions and and starting these
conversations so like if I could if I
could snap my fingers and change
anything I would change all these people
that are sitting in their house on their
couch and have an opinion but aren't
sharing it to start sharing it and to
start having these conversations and I
think that sometimes these polar
opposites get to the standstill because
they're just like so off of each other
that if like the sensible middle ground
would start to have some of these
conversations like we can merge some of
these things and get a lot more things
done it just feels like we're at a
standstill on things that we don't need
to be able to stand still on and it's
either A or B and there's nothing in
between that can that can you know
smooth out the middle I love that yeah
get the middle more empowered to spread
that it's creativity and nuance out and
try and bring people together do you
think we're in a simulation I do that
tell us more why when I think of
simulation I think of the movie matrix
and I think this is real you know I I
don't think there's what is real yeah
well I I just know that my physical body
probably is going to exist for about 78
years right and and so all these things
that are happening now just like I don't
think I don't think there's do-overs on
any of these things you know and so so I
think that the this time on earth is is
the physical nature this is your
physical one physical chance to
have a life on earth and beyond you know
I believe in heaven and I believe our
souls you know go to heaven and and and
so while I'm here like I don't think
it's Soumya huh I don't really think
it's a simulation I just think it's a
stage there's like pre birth and then
birth and life and then then death and
we can a post life and and I think
they're all stages mm-hm
what do you think is the most beautiful
thing in the world who I think the most
beautiful thing is the hope of a child
like they're so pure and you know I
think of I think of just the fact that
they've never been predisposed of any
notions or what for them literally
anything is possible and until it has
been taken away from them and so like
just like that purity of you know the
night the naivete of a child and and the
hope of a child and and so I think
that's that's really you know when we're
trying to solve things like the transit
it's not really for you and me it's like
for our kids and that aren't even born
one day and so it's for these future
generations selfless service yeah the
possibility to kind of endless I think
that's awesome just awesome love that
purity likewise Jason this has been so
awesome thank you so much for joining us
on the show and teaching us about
innovation and the city of Sioux Falls a
blast
these ten months have been a blur and
and I love talking about it and sharing
it you know ten months ago this was not
a real thing and now it's real it's a
Chad trying to tell as many people about
it as possible because it's just like
really cool and impactful work and
future of cities I think but that's I
think every city is dealing with some of
the same issues that we're dealing with
and so if if there's other cities that
see what we're doing and they can take
pieces of what we're doing and put
city I think that's super super powerful
totally different from the private
sector where it's like you have these
secrets and you keep them all to
yourself
yeah and the privates in the public
sector you want to share and collaborate
as much as possible and so help each
other in that sense I love that aspect
about it
yeah openness and transparency in that
sense thank you again for coming on
super show conversation thanks everyone
for tuning in we greatly appreciate it
we'd love to hear your thoughts in the
comments below in the episode let us
know what you're thinking about
innovation in general future cities in
general check out the links in the bio
below Sioux Falls org as well as Jason's
Twitter and LinkedIn profiles have more
conversation through your friends your
families co-workers people online about
the future of cities and the topics that
we talked about also support the artists
the entrepreneurs the spiritual leaders
organizations in your communities that
you believe and support them and help
them grow support simulation our links
are in the bio below to our paypal
patreon crypto-currency you can design
cool merch and get paid all those links
are in the bio below and also go and
build the future everyone manifest your
dreams into the world we love you very
much thank you for tuning in and we will
see you soon peace
[Music]